[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
is he alive
and with your help I'd like to keep it
that way
but they're walking into a trap
your orders are to deliver a message
calling off tomorrow morning's attack
if you don't we will lose sixteen
hundred men
your brother among them
[Music]
[Music]
that is only one way this one ends
lost Man Standing
what the hell are you doing
[Music]
if you fail
it will be a massacre
[Music]
good luck
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Jordan Belford the year I
turned 26 I made 49 million dollars
which really pissed me off because it
was three shy of a million a week
we're making a name for ourselves
[Music]
stock is going to go up down sideways or
in circles you know what the guys is oh
fugazi it's a fake yeah
fairy dust
was all this legal absolutely not we
were making more money than we knew what
to do with it don't work for you man
yeah my money taped to your boobs
technically you do work for me
[Music]
FBI any kind of booze you might want the
bureau forbids us from drinking
follow
I'm doing fine
but there's nowhere to go and there's no
way to slow
how does this actually work it's a big
money sign they get launched at the time
they stick this is their gift okay
they're built to be thrown like a lawn
dart
stop Safety First safety is safety is
first you don't want to get a bad
reputation
baby
[Music]
[Music]
come
on
[Music]
I heard you've been spending a lot of
time at your auntie house as a couch
life you got my woman and my baby living
there it's hard man you know everybody
can't do what you do really what I do
getting played out right where the money
at why you gotta be so ruthless cuz I
make a few changes what do you think
you're going I'm just trying to get home
I gotta talk to my moms like that
[Music]
change the situation
would you take it
just hit that first be hard all right
you cruising down the street all right
you're listening to Compton's very own
ice cube Easy E and Dr Dre I gotta tell
you you are witnessing history
you guys you have a unique voice the
world needs to hear are you going NWA
let's give them NWA
[Music]
this is only the tip of the iceberg
gentlemen what's going on what do you
have in that bag are you kidding me you
can't take that in the bus
[Music]
our art is a reflection of our reality
you guys supposed to be somewhere these
are artists rap is not an art you cannot
come down here and harass my clients
because of what they look like
[Music]
listen to be honest with you I don't
know anything about hip-hop but I know
that you're special
you want to be involved with this
Gangsta life
here we go speak a little truth and
people lose their mind
this isn't the Crips and bloods this is
a threat from the federal government
[Music]
we can keep going man we can take over
the goddamn world
[Music]
questions
what the hell is your delay Captain The
Waiting sir Waiting For What private dos
who the hell is private dos
I was dreamed about being a doctor but
uh
didn't get my school
I can't stay here while all them go
fight for me but you figure this war is
just going to fit in with your ideas
well everybody else is taking life I'm
gonna be saving it that's gonna be my
way to serve
the personal gear from the United States
government designed to bring depth to
the enemy I'm sorry Sergeant I can't
touch a gun
don't kill no sir you know quite a bit
of killing does occur in war private dos
does not believe in violence do not look
to him to save you on the battlefield
that's the question of religion I think
this is countless
because you weren't like anyone
please
with the world so settled tearing itself
apart
doesn't seem like such a bad thing to me
to want to put a little bit of it back
together
private does you are free to run into
the Hellfire of battle without a single
weapon to protect yourself
[Music]
I'm gonna get you home
and you gotta see
I did this
we'll have to go back up tomorrow
and then I'm gonna go up there without
you
[Music]
help me go ahead and trust me
[Music]
please Lord help me get one more
help me get one more
[Music]
front hook ankle hook knee hook come
here you can do the carousel
to switch and rap
[Applause]
[Music]
minus 40 is 160.
[Music]
I just want to take care of my grandma
maybe go shopping every once in a while
when I was a kid I always wanted to work
with animals I was close
they stole from everybody hardworking
people lost everything and not one of
these douchebags went to jail the game
is rigged and it does not reward people
who play by the rules
it's like robbing a bank except you get
the keys
are you in
these are my co-workers jobs please what
if somebody calls the cops and says what
I spent five thousand dollars at a strip
club send help
we're family now damn a family with
money
and when would you say that things got
out of control
[Music]
[Music]
show the guy went back three more times
she must have liked it
diamonds on my neck I like morning sex
but nothing in this world
we didn't do anything wrong you know
Tony wouldn't let this happen I'm gonna
text him gave her her phone back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I'm not around
so very special
I need to do something substantial in
order to get the attention of the clubs
why because they're exclusive and fun
and they lead to a better life
people want to go on the internet and
check out their friends so why not build
a website that offers that friends
pictures profiles I'm talking about
taking the entire social experience of
college and putting it online
two hours thousand twenty two thousand
this idea is potentially worth millions
of dollars millions you stole our
website they're saying we stole the
Facebook I know what it said so did we a
million dollars isn't cool you know it's
cool a billion dollars you're going to
get left behind it's moving faster
let's sue him in federal court I can't
wait to stand over your shoulder and
what you write if you guys were the
inventors of Facebook you haven't met to
Facebook is there anything that you need
to tell me your actions could have
permanently destroyed everything I've
been working on did you like being a
joke do you want to go back to that Mark
time
intentionally breaching security
violating copyrights violating
individual privacy
your best friend is suing you for 6 00
million dollars
[Music]
as for the charges
I believe I deserve some recognition
from this board
I'm sorry
yes
I don't understand which part
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you've tested positive for HIV have you
ever used intravenous drugs have you
ever engaged in homosexual
you made a mistake because that ain't me
Mr Woodruff the estimate you have 30
days left
the news flash yeah ain't nothing out
there can kill Ron Woodruff in 30 days
and drugs they just released protesting
and I know this hospital is one of the
stops and need it it doesn't work that
way Ms Georgia where are you going
they got Good Meds out of Mexico it's
better than what you can get here in the
states yes it's protein totally
non-toxic and you can't buy this in the
USA not approved you could be making a
fortune off of this
I'm actually an amazing anything to
declare not a they're importing illegal
drugs for sale it's a very serious
offense they're not illegal they're
merely unapproved I've been looking for
you Lone Star that's Tinkerbell unless
you got more cash for new clients I'm
busy you don't deserve our money cut you
in five percent 25 take it or leave it
welcome to the Dallas Buyers Club
be treating these people ah they're
treating themselves and I ain't selling
drugs I'm selling membership
Walker or [ __ ] these are patient yes sir
you're also the names of players on the
Dallas Cowboys that's a hell of a
coincidence what the hell is it I have a
court order for me to go to confiscate
any and all non-fda approved supplements
we need new Supply check Amsterdam China
and Israel we've been doing business
with you
why are we here nice restaurant
beautiful woman that's where I feel like
a human again
Mr Woodruff what is going on people are
dying you're nothing more than a common
drug dealer
TJ this is rayon freaking homo
[Music]
[Music]
take it home
[Music]
I want to ask you what part of the
country you come from I originate from
Canada I guess where that is well I know
where Canada is I've been there myself
they'll travel for a Slave
Sullivan Northam is an expert player on
the violin
I was born a free man lived with my
family in New York they're good for your
mother until the day I was deceived to
Solomon kidnapped sold into slavery
thank you
foreign
how you feel now my name is Solomon
North I'm a free man and you have no
right whatsoever to detain you're no
free man you're nothing but a Georgia
Runaway
we're down to the river Jordan and
that's servant I don't obey his Lord
shall be beaten with many stripes
that's scripture the condition of your
laborers it's all wrong and my property
you say that with pride I say this fact
man does how he pleases with his
property you come here come here days
ago I was with my family in my home now
you tell me all this laws if you want to
survive do and say as little as possible
I thought you know something I did as
instructed there's something wrong it's
wrong with the instruction Master bought
you here to work anymore I learned you a
hundred lashes I know what it like to be
the object of massive Smash in his own
time got a lot of manager mom
fall into despair
upon it till freedom is opportunity
foreign
[Music]
we're not winning it
if you speak a word of what I'm about to
show you you will be executed for high
treason
beautiful
greatest encryption device in history
and the Germans use it for all
Communications everyone thinks Enigma is
unbreakable let me try and we'll know
for sure Mr Turing do you know how many
died because of it
did three while we've been having this
conversation
gentlemen meet Mr Turing we used to work
together then I'm afraid these men would
only slam me down popular at school way
short on staff we get more stuff then
you have six minutes to complete the
task it's not even possible no it takes
me eight
five minutes and 34 seconds you said to
do it in under six what is it that we're
really doing we're going to break an
unbreakable Nazi code and win the war oh
you know to pull off this irascible
genius routine one actually has to be a
genius
I'm designing a machine that will allow
us to break every message every day
instantly
you're going to need all the help you
can get and they are not going to help
you if they do not like you have you
decrypted a single German message you
will never understand the importance of
what I am creating here our patience has
expired no
if you fire Helen well then you'll have
to fire me me too and me
better bloody work
Helen you do not have to do this alone
what are you doing what's going on Navy
thinks that one of us is a Soviet spy
you've got more secrets than the best of
them what if I don't fancy her in that
way can't tell anyone no it's illegal
I'm just a mathematician sometimes it is
the people who no one imagines anything
I can imagine
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
where are you
[Music]
no one warned us
no one said you are going to lose both
engines at a lower altitude than any jet
in history
this was dual engine loss at 2 800 feet
followed by an immediate water landing
with 155 Souls on board
no one has ever trained for an incident
like that
our job is to investigate how a plane
ended up in the Hudson River
it's not a crash it was a forced water
landing simulations showed that you
could make it back to the airport not
possible I felt it go
[Music]
have you had any troubles at home
this is the captain
brace for impact
hundreds of people in that place
over 40 years in the air but in the end
I'm going to be judged on 208 seconds
there are rich teams and there are poor
teams then there's 50 feet of crap and
then there's nothing welcome to open
my jobs take this team to a championship
I need more money we're not New York
we're not going to compete with 120
million dollar payroll we've got to
think differently
couldn't be to buy players your goal
should be to buy wins who are you here
is 25 players that have been overlooked
by every other team for one reason or
another like an Island of Misfit Toys in
here is a championship team one that we
could afford who's a kid the kid is the
new assistant GM we're gonna shake
things up tell them
do you want me to speak
we're not pointing you again it's the
new direction of the open eggs we are
card counts at the blackjack table we're
going to turn the odds on the casino you
don't put a team together with a
computer Billy adapt to die
Billy Bean has come in and tried to
reinvent a system now it's just not
working out they call it Moneyball
I think that he bought a ticket of the
Titanic
hey daddy do you think you'll lose your
job what like go on the internet
sometimes well don't go on the internet
watch TV or talk to people
[Music]
do you believe in this thing or not 100
[Music]
listen up you may not look like a
winning team but you are one
so
play like one tonight
[Applause]
we're doing something really unexpected
and special and the whole city is
feeling it if we win this team we change
the game for good
it's better work
I'm just kidding
[Music]
good morning everyone it is seven
o'clock here in canyonland USA hey Aaron
mom still has not heard from you will
you just call her please I'll talk to
you soon and this morning on the boulder
we have a very special guest Aaron
Ralston
oh my gosh it's a real pleasure to be
here I think
I think oh
thank you
hey you're lost I'm a guide what do you
say see I'm something of a big hard hero
oh you have to remember but everything
will be okay
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oops
[Music]
this marks 24 hours of being stuck been
chipping away I'm Gonna Keep Holding
anything I have my 150 milliliters of
water left which should keep me alive
till tomorrow night if I'm lucky
and that's it
Mom Dad I haven't appreciated you
because I know that I could I love you
guys and I'll always be with you
[Music]
[Music]
don't give up and do not give up
[Music]
yeah some guy called over here but
doctor he's looking for a driver you
interested I am not a medical doctor I'm
a musician I'm about to embark on a
concert to work in the Deep South what
other experience do you have
public relations do you foresee any
issues in working for a black man you
and a deep south there's gonna be
problems Palms me you're gonna write me
a letter no problems
tell me that don't smell bad I've never
had fried chicken in my life do people
love the Fried Chicken we have a very
narrow assessment of me Tony yeah right
I'm good
interacting with some of the wealthiest
people in the country it is my feeling
that your addiction could use some
finessing
why are you break my balls because you
can do better Mr Balor
be it Dolores I saw Dr Shirley play the
piano he's like a genius I think I
prefer not to get grease on my blanket
grease on my blanket this gentleman says
that I'm not permitted to die in here
I'm afraid not
how does he smile and shake their hands
like that because it takes courage to
change people's hearts
foreign
you know this is pathetic right put this
down the distance between us is breaking
my spirit falling in love with you was
the easiest thing I have ever done PS
because the kids that's like clinging a
cowbell at the end of shock the code
which is seven and that's good
it's perfect
we never win with violence we only win
when you maintain your dignity you don't
know your own people you missed a big
shot doing concerts for rich people so
if I'm not black enough and if I'm not
white enough then tell me sorry what am
I
anyone can sound like Beethoven
your music when you do
that
[Music]
what do we do about the bones we do this
pick it up Tony squirrels would eat it
anyway pick it up
[Music]
I want to show you something this
rembrand here
people come from all over the world to
see this yeah he's good yeah
to fake apparently come by it's
impossible people believe what they want
to believe because the guy who made this
was so good
and it's real to everybody
notice the master the painter or the
forager
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
just to be a man
[Music]
[Music]
close to a new era
[Music]
I never took a quarter from a phone
booth you stole I just got bigger balls
than you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
they're coming in fast
this is a mask Alabama we are an unarmed
freighter we have two skips approaching
with armed Intruders potential piracy
situation coffee Alabama you should
alert your crew and get your fire hoses
ready
yeah is that it chances are it's just
fishermen they're not here to fish
that ladder 150 degrees
listen up
we have been boarded by armed Pirates
they find you
remember you know the chef they don't
stick together it will be all right
everything gonna be okay
look at me look at me I'm the captain
now
Captain Phillips can you hear me Captain
Phillips can you hear me
[Music]
Russians spy satellite taking pictures
and God knows what get us up there
Harrison we can't justify a space
program that doesn't put anything in
space
we all go end up unemployed riding
around in this pilot jump you're welcome
to walk to 16 miles oh sitting in the
back of the bus
we're putting a human into space we
bring him in too soon he burns up on
re-entry
I need math that doesn't yet exist finds
a mathematician before the Russians
plant a flag on the damn Moon
you have identification on NASA I had no
idea they heard quite a few women
working in the space program
space test group needs a computer
Catherine's a guy for that she can
handle any numbers you put in front of
them never had a colored in here but
don't embarrass me this wasn't empty
last night uh I'm sorry I'm not
you should be an engineer I'm a negro
woman I'm not going to entertain the
impossible I'm standing beneath a
spaceship we are living The Impossible
the IBM data processing system we have
to know how to program it
get it girl that's John Glenn what do
you ladies do for NASA calculate your
trajectories I can't get anywhere
without the numbers
white men it's equal rights I have the
right to see fun in Africa NASA doesn't
commission females for the Engineer
program every time we have a chance to
get ahead I would like to attend today's
briefing there is no protocol for women
attending they move the finish line
you all should be thankful you have jobs
at all
I don't even know if I can keep up in
that room
with the numbers and anyone in that
cabinet
you've been gone for 300 hours it felt
like it to me too you remember where I
need you to be where the hell do you go
every day the colored bathroom is a mile
away
we all get to the peak together we don't
get there at all
more than 50 million people are watching
this launch John from the IBM is wrong
let's get the girls to check the numbers
my gals are ready we can do the work
Colonel Glenn it's good to know NASA
hasn't given up on good old-fashioned
brain time
the Friendship seven has experienced
some sort of a malfunction there's a
real Fireball outside it's getting a
little hot in here in the fight of Our
Lives people
[Music]
friendship seven do you copy over
actions of Iran have shocked the
Civilized world
everything our Embassy has been seized
and more than 60 American citizens
continue to be held as hostages if we're
going to go then we need to go now
[Music]
foreign
six of the hostages went on a back exit
where are they the Canadian ambassador's
house we've got revolutionary guards
going door to door
these people die they die badly the
White House who wants the six of them
out what we like for this are bicycles
deliver the six bikes provide them with
maps or you could just send in training
wheels and meet them at the border with
Gatorade
It's Gonna Take a Miracle to get them
out
hey man what are we watching I got an
idea they're a Canadian film crew for a
science fiction movie I fly into Tehran
we all fly out together as a film crew I
need you to help me make a fake movie so
you want to come to Hollywood to act
like a big shot without actually doing
anything
yeah it'll fit right in you need a
script Argo science fantasy Adventure
RuneScape Mars desert we need an exotic
location to shoot you need a producer if
I'm doing a fake movie it's gonna be a
fake hit you don't have a better bad
idea than this this is the best bad idea
we have sir by far
you have 72 hours to get them out
they're getting a visitor you gotten
people out this way before no
you're asking us to trust you with our
lives this is what I do and I've I've
never left anyone behind
I know who they are and they know
they're hiding out it's over Tony
they stay here they will be taken
probably not alive
[Applause]
we're responsible for these Bitcoins
foreign
[Music]
you really believe your little story is
going to make a difference when there's
a gun to our heads I think my little
story is the only thing between you and
a gun to your head
[Music]
[Music]
hey Mike you're gonna give yourself a
day off now I'm actually going into the
office come home soon I love you
this article was about saving young
people's lives you said write it up I
said write it up not make it up I did
the best with what I had you have a
future ahead of you Mike but not here
you know to be honest I'm relieved it's
over with the times
you turn into a real prick working for
them
hello
hi I'm a reporter with The Oregonian I
wanted to get your side on the Christian
Longo story who he murdered his entire
family why are you telling me this
because when they apprehended him he
said he was Mike Finkel of the New York
Times
did he say anything at all about why he
claimed to be me I hoped you might be
able to tell me that he was just a
regular guy an intelligent sane man he
comes home one night and kills his wife
and kids it makes no sense
thank you for seeing me Mr Longo call me
Chris so why me I followed your whole
career I guess I felt like I knew you I
want to tell you my side of this only
you maybe at this point it doesn't
matter
truth always matters it always seems to
matter to you it's just a once in a
lifetime story don't you see this as a
second chance or an outcast that's not
the man I wanted to be I don't know this
is the man he wants to be
hello Jill hey it's nice to meet you
Chris well Mike's he's been a real
friend of me I just hope that we can be
friends too
I believe we're dealing with an
exceptionally dangerous man you had a
choice of so many stories to tell and
you chose his actually he picked me he
didn't pick you he used you we think
he's already some bigger game plan this
isn't just about me who do you have to
protect
I can't say you think he's innocent
don't you my whole reputation's on the
water don't give up on me are you really
gonna be the man who might set him free
Chris did you do what your accused of
doing
just these I don't want the others come
on man I slept things all the way here
there's people waiting you know you
don't have to be so disrespectful you
have actually carried my books here and
you are Lee Israel oh we have copies of
your latest work right over there
foreign
[Music]
months behind in my rent and my cat is
sick it's four in the afternoon he got
drunk I'm hardly drunk crazy
my suggestion to you is you go out there
and you find another way to make a
living
delightful sign letter Fanny Bryce one
of my favorites I could give you 75. oh
I could give more for better content
it's a bit bland is all
[Music]
yeah I can definitely get a lot more for
this one I mean the PS makes it
Priceless
quite by accident I find myself in a
rather criminal position what criminal
activity could possibly involve in
except a crime of fashion Force I'm
embellishing literary Letters by
prominent writers I love his writing
particularly clever don't you think
caustic way
this is quite something
is a wonderful I thought so too name
your price you were looking at one
month's rent what are you gonna do here
gamble shop drink
does Israel I have a couple of questions
regarding the last letter I purchased
what seems to be the problem
people around older your name's been put
on a list on the list they're literary
Treasures One of a Kind it's my writing
you're impersonating other people
nobody's buying Lee Israel letters
there have been some forgeries going
around to these real looks that way good
you're stealing from me come on get out
of my house that's just supposed to be
something more than this
we're probably looking at some time
Behind Bars what
[Music]
I can't say that I regret any of my
actions in many ways this has been the
best time of my life
[Music]
[Music]